i had nightmares of course for for
i would say for a couple of months you
know waking up
thinking that i'm still in the camps and
i was so
happy that i was in
a real bed
in order to have a little bit of
pleasure let's say which is
there's not too much of it in the camps
i made friends with two polish kids
we didn't get too much sleep and we used
to just get out
real early in the morning because in the
barracks it was just
crying and screaming and praying
and it wasn't unusual that a prisoner
who was laying next to you
to go to sleep when you woke up they
were dead
in any of these camps everything is so
the same day in and day out that when
anything unique happens that is not
on the schedule you always
immediately try to talk about it is this
good news or bad news
one morning they came out and the first
thing we saw
was that there are no guards in their
guard towers
so we are sneaking between the barracks
towards the gate
and lo and behold nobody is there
so we get enough courage to go to the
gate
and we notice there's a heavy chain with
a padlock on it
and it's a very very foggy morning
and we are just dumbfounded all of a
sudden there's a break in the fog
like a mirage and all you see is two
horses with a horseman
as he's coming closer one of the polish
kids says to me
look at his hat and it was a red star a
russian soldier
he comes to the gate and he says
i'm advanced guard nobody can leave the
there are camp sorts of diseases you're
full of lice and you haven't been
washing for months
but he says as he takes out his gun
shoots up the padlock doctors will be
coming medication will be coming food
will be coming very shortly
so the three of us as fast as our skinny
legs can carry us we go to every barrack
in the vicinity open up the door in
every language that we know
just yell in we are free we are free and
you'll never forget that
moment the sounds from the barracks
those who are able to walk out to the
sunlight walk out
those who can't walk are
crawling out i have to pass through a
little area
where there are little bungalows and
this is where the ss families were
staying
and they must have left in a big hurry
because i go into one of the
bungalows and i open up the closet the
clothing in there
open up the pantry food and then i go
into the
bathroom and i turn on the water hot
water
fluffy towels shampoo soap i haven't
seen for a year
i make a little victory dance on my
prison uniform
get in there and take my first hatch
hour in a year
it's wonderful i'm basically i'm trying
to have as many happy moments as
possible at my age you know
you can't take any chances